hey guys welcome back to Boneshaker this
is the last video in this series
not counting the final POV video that I
make which is kind of sad but then again
I did plan to make this the last video
but there were still many different
things that I wanted to do so this video
ended up becoming quite a bit longer
than I expected beforehand and in the
end still a lot gets done in this video
and hopefully it's still pretty
interesting video I'll be starting this
video up with I've said the word video
just about enough times there I'll start
this off with just working on the
backstage area over here
I'll also be working on a motor
underneath the brake run to kind of turn
that into some interesting machinery and
have a bit of steampunk elements in
there as well I also be working on a
restaurant on the still empty side of
this park which is gonna have like an
interesting English Queen and sort of
style to it and I'll be working on some
spurious more uninteresting stuff as
well as a little control room for the
flat ride and very interesting actually
the lighting for this ride because I
haven't actually worked on the lighting
in a single episode so far so that is
something I really still wanted to do
now about these backsides I kind of
wanted to make this in in a way that I
would kind of look like it could be part
of a different Park and I know I've set
this multiple times but I've never
really explained like what this sort of
idea behind it is and why I sort of
chose to do it this way I figured it
would be nice to have it laid out in
such a way that this part or this little
coaster could realistically be part of a
bigger park and the way I sort of tried
to do that here is by having two
entrances on two sides which is kind of
like I believe it is the south towards
the entrance but not entirely sure and
the part on the Left right there and I
wanted to leave the other corners pretty
much unconnected so it could kind of be
while the corner of a park that you can
put this into and have the connecting
parts actually connect with buildings
around it not just to be a nice
transition into this area but also to
have like this sort of thing that Disney
has as well having the having the
buildings between the different areas so
you can have backstage things back there
and yeah basically make it the place
where you want to have the buildings
which is what I wanted to do over here
as well so they could potentially
hypothetically if this were part of a
bigger parts these buildings good on the
other side of the towers hook up two
buildings in a completely different
theme or even different areas or a sort
of central hub to a park and that's the
overall sort of idea of this which is
also why I don't think I can really well
keep going with this Park and turn this
one Boneshaker
area into a bigger park because for one
it's kind of in a really awkward corner
of the park it really sits awkwardly
near the entrance which doesn't really
work if I want to turn it into a bigger
park and it's also really laid out with
this idea of this area with the
buildings being the connection to like a
larger sort of park that's kind of laid
out like it is a Disney park and there
is no way I can actually fill that in
around this so I rather just kind of
move on to different Park files with the
different projects that I wanna start on
after this not to mention that my
computer was already kind of screaming
in agony while I was building this ride
so I don't imagine if I would build an
entire park around this my PC could
handle that very well even though it's
not that bad of a PC it definitely isn't
there's just so many different pieces
everywhere and thousands of buildings in
here that it just wouldn't really work
now moving on to the break run over here
I actually had some inspiration from a
really strange place that being the
little motor of cannon I probably
butchered that pronunciation which is a
coaster in Hansa Park it's one of the
biggest coasters in Europe actually you
opened pretty recently and it's a girl
our infinity coaster and it has a really
interesting lift Hill which is inside a
building but it also has a pretty
interesting lift hill subsystem behind
it which I could find some pictures of
and I figured that would be a good way
to start with a sort of break system to
make some machinery that could at least
be related to coasters somewhat and
could also kind of look like it belongs
in a steampunk theme even though I have
no idea how the mechanics behind lift
hills or well I don't have an xx
eeeh of what they should look like and
how they should be pieced together so
that is something I didn't really have
any knowledge of I just wanted to make
sure that this could kind of look like
it could realistically you know be a
sort of brake motor kind of thing and
the idea was pretty simple
I took the wheels from the left sole
system which is kind of strange since it
is a brake run over here and there is no
need for any kind of cable system though
there could realistically be like a
cable sort of brake run system anyway
it's just kind of like making something
that looks like it could potentially
work in a sort of fantasy setting like
steampunk but that doesn't necessarily
have to have any sort of specific
mechanics or have to be completely
functional it's kind of more about the
fantasy gear and I pretty much just
figured I could keep on adding little
parts everywhere kind of make them
unrecognizable of the parts that they
actually are and just work with that
until it looks like something that I
figure I could actually go it and
basically this is going to be the motor
on top of that I wanted to have the
catwalks for the lift hill or for the
brake run I should say and make those a
bit fancy as well like I want to make
every single part of the ride also fit
with the theme so don't really want to
have any generic catwalks or Genet
generic looking lifts Hill but kind of
put them in the theme as well and on the
side of this I also wanted to have a
small steam machine just to make it look
as if it also had a way to power itself
and not just be a brake run machine with
nothing attached to it that could
actually power it in a sort of steam
environment here now I was also playing
around with like adding some things on
the sides and stuff like that but didn't
want to go with that in the end since it
really draws a lot of attention to the
brake run itself and while I wanted to
turn this into something that kind of
fits with the rest of the theme and
doesn't leave this area to empty I did
want to have something that well stays
really low and doesn't draw too much
attention since there is a really
important sideline I feel which comes
from the Main Street onto the hill of
the lift Hill and I really wanted to
preserve that and have
a really big sort of structure in here
like having a huge gray current system
or having a transfer track even could
really break that sight line I felt so I
wanted to keep this pretty open or I
wanted to keep this really compact and
mostly underneath the coaster tracks
instead of going or up in the air just
to make this no just to make this area
still a bit open and keep that sight
line in there and keep the pretty good
view on the station as well which is
pretty well not worthy especially as you
look from the path which is just
underneath the ellipse Hill Hill and
which is also something that I really
wanted to keep in there so this is going
to be the steam machine which is gonna
be pretty simple I went with the very
similar real idea of the wheels that I
had for the little except it's just one
in this case and it's quite a bit
smaller than that one and the machine in
general is just gonna be pretty simple
it's just based off of real steam
machines but it's obviously a very
simplified version and the texture is
don't entirely match up so there's quite
a bit of fantasy involved in making this
actually somewhat yeah like it actually
looks like a steam machine but it's the
general idea to have a steam machine
kind of stick out over here and just or
I should say steam engine I have no idea
what I'm saying
and just have that in there put some
details around it just make everything
look a bit more interesting in a bit
more alive without completely clogging
it up because it was also quite happy
with having this area choose to be a
small little cross area without any
foliage or anything like that I think
many people really do have this sort of
urge to fill every empty spot of a park
with well trees or any kind of other
scenery but especially in this case I
wanted to also leave the foliage pretty
empty in this area just to not draw too
much attention with the foliage either
it's more or less just there to make
everything come together a bit more and
be a part of this general landscape but
not be a way to fill it up I think
especially if you start placing trees in
empty areas everything really quickly
becomes this jungle and you can't really
see too many things and it becomes
really crammed
and compacts and that's the sort of idea
that I'd wanted to avoid here moving on
I wanted to make a restaurants just
because I don't have one yet and I also
figured it would be a nice sort of way
to mess around with a different building
style which is also pretty common in
Victorian England which is sort of like
the general Queen and building style
though I'm not talking about the very
old Queen Anne style with the Revival
style that was pretty popular in the
Victorian era and so something I wanted
to play around with a bit and I figured
it would fit pretty well for a
restaurant it's pretty common I think
for like mansions or sometimes probably
a row houses as well or terraces I
should probably say and I think it would
work pretty well for a restaurant since
it works pretty well as a standalone
building and it's a pretty open style
that I figured it could also work pretty
well that the buildings that I already
have in the main streets and the idea
behind the general Queen Anne style is
pretty simple and mostly just
rectangular buildings with a pediment in
the front and that's pretty much all I
can remember and I think often the doors
also kind of stick out like they have
little stairs leading to them or in this
case I figured it would be nice to have
that part with the door stick out a bit
but instead of having a door have the
marble shop in there I would have loved
to actually have a door in there and
have all sorts of restaurant interiors
but I figured this would be the best way
to make this restaurant actually look
like a restaurant but make it functional
in the game as well and also pretty well
Queen and kind of thing that I really
wanted to do with this building is have
that sort of corner Tower with a spire
on top of the corner there and put a
pediment on the other corner which is
pretty unusual I do have to say I don't
think there are too many pediments that
are placed on the corner of a building
they're usually right in the middle just
to have that sort of triangular middle
facade of a building but I just figured
it would work best in the on the side
here and keep the door and the entrance
to the restaurant itself right in the
middle of the building and the roof was
kind of
kind of a thing that wasn't entirely
right I guess since well in a perfect
world I would have been able to use like
the very typical English tiled roof here
which I wish I could but there is no way
to actually do that with the things in
the game at the moment I kind of
probably could have used the tiled roof
from the Spanish set but it's just got
that very Mediterranean color to it it's
way too light and it doesn't have the
right slope so it wouldn't really work
in this case so I figured this weird
wooden combination was the next best
thing that kind of looks like it at
least it doesn't look terrible and
that's why I figured I would go with
that and I wanted to get some like some
nice simple rectangular windows in here
but all the windows in the game at the
moment they all have these decorations
except forward well the very modern one
but that one wouldn't really work out so
I can't wanted to simplify these windows
bit and put the very small that's the
bottoms actually other windows on top of
these windows you just make them
rectangular boxes which fits in more
with the style I believe and just put
that in there and there were a number of
things I kinda wanted to try with this
corner Tower but I eventually ended up
changing that quite a bit because as you
can see at the moment it's a pretty
fancy tower and I don't really like fat
towers especially if they're trying to
be a queen an Tower which is just a bit
more elegant bit more a bit of what a
bit more narrow I did I never said pitch
and yeah I did want to tone that down a
little bit make it a bit more slim at
some point in the future though top of
the roof works pretty well in the end
and I'm pretty happy with how that came
out especially the tower just as a sort
of side focal point works pretty well
with the towers that I already had in
the main streets and works pretty well
just to make this building a bit more
interesting because I wanted to make
something that looks really English
especially with the chimneys and the
brick use and everything like that but I
didn't want to make something that's
very boring and truth be told it's it's
a very sort of common English style to
have these green and houses which are
just rectangles with a a hip roof on top
of it and
very windows and some very chimneys and
that's pretty much it but they're kind
of boring to look at and this is a theme
park after all so I wanted to give
myself a bit more freedom and mess
around with more fancy things that were
here and really wanted to try this tower
out for that reason it was just kind of
tricky to get the exact sort of round
besides that I wanted so I believe I did
yeah I did redo that a couple of times
that just got that outs but that
actually took quite a while to get the
exact size because well either it was
just too narrow or it was too thick and
it often didn't exactly work out but I'm
pretty happy with the dimensions as it
is at the moment it could have still
been a bit smaller and the top of the
spire or I should say the bottom of the
spire at the top of the tower is a bit
heavy at the moment but I'm pretty happy
with how it turned out and how it all
works with the chimneys on top of the
building as well and at the very least I
am pretty happy with how sort of English
it turned out it's definitely not
perfect but I I think it's got the sort
of atmosphere of an English building
pretty well and I'm really happy with
how that turned out
now just because the roof was looking
really empty I wanted to put a dormer on
the roof as well which I figured it
would work pretty well as just a really
big doorman and some final touches that
I did want to add just because many of
the things that are used in this case
since we can't really recolor anything
and we can't use textures I ended up
having many whites textures on that
building which works quite well with the
brick texture which is very dark so it's
nice contrast there but it's all very
white and brown and in general it kind
of fits in the color palettes of planet
coaster which is a bit well something
that you can't really avoid but one of
the things that still kind of nags me
and I try to avoid as much as I can is
the fact that since we can't really
recolor anything yet and there aren't
that many textures in the game
everything sort of has the same colour
scheme and you can make just about
anything you want with these pieces but
you can't get rid of the textures so you
always end up having these white accents
the same sort of general colors to your
builds and I trying to at least mix it
up as much as I can by using some of
these smaller pieces to sort of recolor
some things and I was kind of hoping to
make this a bit less looking like every
single other building I had in here just
by having that little sort of beige
elements in there oh this is kind of
interesting too though I wanted to make
some tables and chairs and this actually
worked surprisingly well and I have to
say this is the first thing I tried I
just literally put these together and
for you that'll work
I'll just use those for the tables and
chairs but I think you might actually
want to experiment quite a bit more with
the tables and chairs because there's
definitely a lot of possibilities there
and you can just save them as single
buildings and copy them over and you can
probably also make some umbrellas out of
some stuff as well I'm definitely wanted
to find out especially with you wooden
pieces you can make some pretty good
wooden umbrellas for like an African
theme or something like that anyway
moving on I also wanted to make a sign
for the entrance of the ride which
doesn't per se make too much sense from
a theme park perspective like you
normally just see the sign in front of
the ride or the general area of one
certain ride but in here I figured I had
this nice iron thing and it was always
more or less the plan to put the
Boneshaker sign over here and since
there is no way to put your own text on
signs yet and since there is no
Boneshaker sign in the game very
surprisingly I figured it would be nice
to try and make my own I've seen a
couple of people also try and use some
different pieces to make like letters
out of things to make custom signs and
there are definitely many possibilities
with this as well I just figured this
would work best since it fits the scale
of the of the bridge pretty well there
and it also has that nice page sort of
brassy steampunky color to it and this
foliage isn't meant to exactly be
realistic it's more or less just there
to fence off the general area of the
coaster and make sure that all the well
unfinished lands of empty cross plains
on the outside of the coaster aren't
really visible when you're inside the
park more or less that's the
idea just for a bit of more realism I
figured this is a really small building
for a restaurant especially for a theme
park so the idea behind the building is
kind of to have the building itself not
be that big but hide a pretty big sort
of backstage area behind the building
where you could fit like the restaurant
and the kitchen and everything into so
that's what I figured I would do over
here
just to make it you know appear like a
pretty small building while in reality
there's quite a bit hidden behind it
much like you I often see with mad
houses or sometimes even restaurants I
think in real life as well and the same
goes for this area I didn't want to
place plenty of trees around here just
to make sure that you don't see the
outside parts of the park so you don't
like lose the sort of immersion when
you're in the park I just always like
placing enormous forests around the
parts that are finished to block out the
rest of the world which is not finished
and one last thing that I stole it's a
build over here is a control room which
is nothing special really but from a
realism standpoint I really just wanted
to have a control room for this flat
ride since without one there's no way to
really control this ride and it's kind
of awkward as well because it is a pre
it isn't already placed right but it
doesn't actually have anyone controlling
it which is pretty strange like there is
no control board or anything and just
for a bit of realism I wanted to add
this more cabin where well theoretically
that would be like a control board and
everything and all sorts of buttons and
well all sorts of stuff I don't know too
much about that to be honest but all
sorts of stuff to actually control the
ride and there would be like somebody's
sitting inside there to make sure that
everything goes all right and that's
basically the purpose of this little
building and why I wanted to get it in
here it's nothing fancy and the only
reason why I am making it a bit fancy is
to not make it too immersion breaking
because anything is better than just a
simple plastic cabin so yeah it's just a
really simple building I just wanted to
get it in here more or less for realism
purposes another I'm working on this
ride anyway I want to address a few
comments that I've been getting about it
like some comments whether
this actually fits with the steampunk
theme I basically chose this ride not
because I think it fits that well with
the steampunk theme especially the
colors are really off from the rest of
this part of the park which is kind of
awkward and something I wish I could do
something about but I chose it just
because ahem and there were quite a few
comments about this as well airships and
in general blimps and things like that
are very commonly associated with a
steampunk theme and there was no way
that I would actually get like a flying
airship or anything like that into this
park because that would just be
completely unrealistic and I still want
to keep this as if it could be a
realistic part of a different park but
since I couldn't really get that in in
that way I figured that flat ride still
has some air balloons in it which do
have some sort of steampunk connotations
do it and I think that would be why they
ride at least fits decently into this
part of the park though I'm still not
that happy about the colors now moving
on I also wanted to go into the lighting
of the park and I figured beforehand
this would be like a breeze to do and I
could do this fairly quickly but it
actually turned out to take quite a bit
of time since it's just you know with
the new system there's so much freedom
which is definitely amazing with how you
place lights and everything and it makes
the already amazing lighting system in
the game that much more fun and flexible
but it just takes a huge amount of time
to actually get these in every position
and make sure that the buildings are
well lit up especially because I wanted
to make sure that these lights would
also be in somewhat realistic places in
that you could potentially just sink the
lights into the ground and make all the
lights disappear and make them invisible
and not have them be such nuisances all
over your pots and things like that but
I at least wanted to make all the lights
visible and not sink them into the
ground or walls or anything since it
kind of felt like heating and instead I
try to hide the lights into different
parts so that you could kind of still
see the lights but you don't really see
them as out in the open so many of the
lights are hidden behind planters or on
buildings on the other side
lighting up buildings on the other side
which is also a position which is better
than just sitting in the middle of a
pile in the middle of a path or I kind
of put them into walls huh or put them
into barrels things like that just make
sure that the lights are in places that
they could kind of realistically sit in
but at the same time make sure that
those places are not too obvious and
that they don't pretty much well sit in
the middle of the paths or in the middle
of scenery and just kind of the grade
the scenery in that way
and when it comes to the color scheme
it's pretty simple I wanted to go for
some brassy colors so most of the lights
are just a mix of the red and the yellow
lights which works pretty well you can
also just kind of overlap them as in not
reposition them just place a red light
and place a yellow light shortly after
in the exact same position works pretty
well looks pretty decent
I got a nice sort of orange glow to it
and where I wanted to get like some
extra lights to make things light a bit
more it usually worked to just add a
white light in there so most of the
lights are just yellow and red with a
couple of white lights mixed in there as
well and when it comes to sort of the
strategy of what I wanted to line up
most you can probably tell at this point
I just wanted to line up the wienies
most of all so the tower is on top of
the hill are very lights the station and
the buildings in the main street are
pretty lights and I just wanted to make
the rest of the park especially these
very heavy in theming areas I didn't
want to make them light up and I didn't
want to leave any dark corners
especially around here but just make
them lights like a little bit less heavy
than the towers so make sure that the
lights are a bit further away and well
not have as many lights as I would have
on the big towers or the station and
where I could actually some of the
lanterns worked out pretty well as well
but still I have to say this goes
especially for the pass the lanterns
kind of set a mood that kind of creates
a general atmosphere which is really
nice but they don't actually light
anything up and as you can tell even
though I have the lights everywhere on
the lanterns there
which is so incredibly small you don't
even see the path line up underneath
them which is really awkward because now
the paths are kind of dark and I don't
really see any way to get rid of that
the actual path lights as in the lights
that is actually meant to be a path
light does work pretty well too unlikely
paths up but just because I wanted to
have these lanterns that fit with the
theme it is a bit dark at night anyway
that is just about it for this
time-lapse I am running out of videos to
show you so I'm basically going to
record a POV of this ride and have some
nice cinematic shots along with that and
I'll upload that sometime soon so thank
you guys for watching this series and
make sure to stick around for the final
video